the fourth move I want to consider is C3
whereupon I recommend you capture in the
center and then play our trademark idea
namely Queen to B6
so as we are attacking on B2
white has tried three options
and I can't believe when I look at the
database that B3 is by far the most
popular choice however after this black
is completely winning
how well we start with Knight to C6
attacking on this Pawn
this Pawn can't move further as Queen to
if I check NAB the sweetie so
accordingly white has tried to defend
this Pawn either with Knight to F3 or E3
and in both the case black has this nice
tactical shot
can you see it
just look at this
if I
what a move
well white has two choices
number one if you take back with the
bishop then we have this nice sequence
Bishop to B for check Knight to D2
now you pressurize this Knight with
Knight to E4
so white has to defend with Knight to F3
and finally The Sting in the tail D6
wins the game on the spot as wherever
the bishop moves our next move is Bishop
to G4
taking the F3 Knight and then take on D2
something which white can see it but
unfortunately he cannot defend it
[Music]
the most natural response here is D
captures E5 but again this goes into the
same direction starting with Bishop to B
for check Knight to D2 Knight to E4
Knight to F3 and this time
we don't have the move D6 but we have
even stronger move namely
time and time this happened in this line
so remember G5
our old good friend
help us to win the game
the point is if white doesn't do
anything then G4 is coming up
so more or less white has to take it and
after this nope you don't take the
bishop but you play this very strong
deflecting move Knight takes E5 so that
we can take this Knight and then munch
on D2 something which is once again
white cannot prevent it
I recently win a very quick game where
my opponent plays this blunder move A3
and what he missed is
Knight catches F3 is a check and after
Pawn takes and Bishop takes D2
probably he doesn't want to give up the
queen so he played King to E2 and give
me the whole
King
well that's kind of fun you can get once
your opponent played the move B3
the second alternate you hear is Queen
to D2
but whenever this happened I really like
the black position because we always get
Tempo with Knight to E4
and before we do this I recommend you
start with Knight to C6 attacking this
pawn and when white defend it now you
play Knight to E4
the point is after Queen to C2
counter-attacking the Black Knight we
have this nice move here namely
night to before
saying why go ahead buddy take the night
the Tactical point is if white is
foolish enough to take this Knight then
after nice deflection move D5 and
suddenly Queen has to give access to
this Knight on the C2 as she has no way
to hide
so nope Queen captures E4 is a bad move
the more accurate response here is Queen
to B3
but after this once again black has this
nice sequence
Queen to A5 looking for the discovery so
white has to block it
after this we play this nice little cute
move
E6
and setting up yet another trap that if
white takes on e4 then we have Knight to
C2 double discover check and nabbing the
rook in the corner
and apart from it if y doesn't take it
the next plan is very obvious we are
looking at Knight to D5 combining with
Bishop to B4 which believe it or not but
gives black a completely winning
Advantage at just 10th move of the game
let me show you how
there's a one high profile game in the
database continue with Knight to F3
whereupon black delivered the goods with
ease not to defy attacking three times
on the night
Rook to Sivan now comes Bishop to B4
and don't forget this poor effort Bishop
is also hanging
so in the game white has to sadly
retrieve the bishop to G3
but then the sequence is very obvious
Bishop takes E3 Pawn take C3 and after
Knight xc3 look at the pathetic King
even though there is a discover check
looming sadly enough this King cannot
move anywhere
well in the game white plays Rook to C2
but after Knight takes A2 discover check
Knight to D2 and now Knight to C3 back
whereupon black is not only a clear too
healthy Pawn up but he has some ongoing
pressure on this poor white cake
last but not least what to do against
the move Queen to C2
please remember guys don't go for the
queen captures D4 here as Queen capture
C8 is actually a checkmate
so first you need to play Knight to C6
attacking this pawn and when a white
Defenders now I recommend you should
play Space gaining move with D5
the point is when white continue with
his favorable Choice Knight to C3 we can
deliver this surprising package
can you see it
yup this typical deflection London move
Bishop to F5 and I think after this
black is in really good shape
first of all you can't take this bishop
in the view of Queen captures B2 with a
good advantage to the black
so that is right out of the equation
the second move Queen to C1 is also very
bad as Knight to B4 creates some huge
problems in the white camp
so all together here white is forced to
play Queen to B3
but this is playing right into Black's
hand as after Queen exchange and the
move A6
yup we enter into the queenless middle
game where the structural weaknesses are
clearly viewers the black cam
white has tried two choices here
number one in one of my Blitz game my
opponent played Knight to B5
taking the advantage of the pin but I
just calmly play Rook to C8 and sadly
enough now white has to go back which is
already losing a tempo as in the game he
played Knight to C7 and after King to d8
I obtained two P's for a rook and in
fact win the game
so nope Knight to bifa is a pretty bad
choice by the White
the more natural responses Knight to F3
trying to finish the development
whereupon black will do the same
first Rook to C8 stopping any piece
intrusion
Bishop to E2
now we play E6 and after White Castles
well the engine suggests you can play
Knight to H5 and black get a very good
game however I insist on preserving my
Bishop so at six is the accurate choice
and from here the game goes into the
normal channel for example H3 Bishop to
E7 where black and castle on the king
side but the fact to remain on the table
is white has this loose double Pawn
where in the upcoming end game a
clear-cut Target and as confirmed by
chess engine
Blackgate a slightly Superior position
finally we reached the main move E3
I am very delighted to share my own
secret here as if you look at the
database
mahimu is not even in top six choices
and this will be a really shocker to
your opponent as it has been not
analyzed in any books and videos
are you ready
just look at this
Knight to defy a star move in the London
Galaxy where we have a very simple
threat
nabbing this bishop so all the game
continues with Bishop to G3
and now yup our consistent approach
Queen to B6 attacking the weak B3 Pawn
well white has the only move here namely
B3 as other moves completely fails for
example if they go Queen to C1 then
black obtain a clear Pawn Advantage at
just sixth move of the game
so that is right out of the equation
what about Knight to C3 well your guess
is equal as mine you can chop on C3 gear
white a double pawn and then continue
with G6
which in fact sets up a very small trail
that if white continue with his natural
peace development such as Knight to F3
then he can lose the game very quickly
and this happens in my game against a
2400 leeches player where I continue
with Bishop to G7 and the big point is
when white developed the bishop
and ready to Castle
black and deliver this nasty punch Queen
to B2 and by force white is losing the
vital Pawn
in fact my opponent made it worst by
playing Bishop to E5 as I exchange the
bishop and then kick this Knight with D6
where unfortunately you might lose more
material after Knight to F3 Queen
capture C3 Knight to D2 and now the
d-pawn is also a goner and at just 13th
move which opening gives you two Pawn
Advantage from Black
so to cut the long story short the only
move here is B3
and after this first we exchange on D4
and then fee and chat over Bishop with
G6
please note white can't play C4 here the
simple reason is this queen check is
very strong and there is a game in the
database where white plays Knight to D2
but after Knight to C3 Queen to C1
black has multiple choice including
Bishop to F6 as well as Knight to E4
so C4 is a very premature move here
the more logical responses
Knight to F3 trying to finish the
development whereupon black deliver
another surprising package Bishop to F6
so idea is this help us to land the
night on their Foursquare
and accordingly as per the database
white has four choices
well I really don't like the move C3
here the simple reason is
after Knight to F4 we are completely
locking down this bishop and if white
wants to Castle on the king side then he
has to give up the dark Square Bishop
which is a completely moral victory for
the black
in one bullet game my opponent tried
Queen to D2 thinking that he's getting
my knight but the problem is after
Knight captures G2 actually black who is
getting the White Queen
the second choice Bishop to C4 oftenly
consider here
but I think again this is a kind of
inaccuracy by white where black can
deliver the goods with Queen chat
the point is after Knight to D2 We can
jump in with Knight to C3
and after Queen to C1
we can liberate all our peace with
Knight to C6
castle and now B5
Force the bishop go to the D3 Square
and what else but yet another London
deflection move you got it
Bishop to fi as this bishop cannot move
simply because of this juicy Fork
to demonstrate how good this position is
for the black let's see a grand master
game where white continue with Rook to
even
defending the folk black plays the
obvious move Bishop takes doubling the
white pawn and then continue with Castle
on the king side
and when white plays the move Queen to
B2
Knight to B5 deliver the decisive punch
the default Pawn is hanging and in the
game white tried the Tactical move A4
which doesn't work out as after Knight
takes D4 Knight takes D4 black plays
Bishop to D2 and this more or less by
force win the cave
how well let's see a forcing
continuation from here Knight Tech C6
attacking the queen Pawn Tech C6 and
when white Saves The Rook
The Sting in the tail Bishop to C3 wins
The Exchange and in fact the cave
last but not least whether your opponent
continue with Bishop to E2 or Bishop to
D3 they both goes into the same
direction let's say Bishop to E2
planning to Castle kingside
and this is exactly the movement where
black delivered this check
if King to F1 then the rook in the
corner become extremely unhappy
so the force response is Knight to D2
and after this you know what to do
yup Knight to C3 attacking the queen
queen to C1
and here I don't like to capture this
bishop instead black should continue
with his peace development Knight to C6
stopping white to Castle
so white has to first save the bishop
whereupon we deliver another nice
tactical move Knight to B4 so there is a
cat and mouse phenomena going on where
white still cannot castle in the view of
Knight takes D3 Pawn text D3 and bye bye
White Queen
so that means Castle is right out of the
equation once black plays Knight to B4
and accordingly the only logical reply
here is A3
getting rid of this Knight but black is
more than happy as white get this double
Pawn
and when we play D6 our last piece get
liberated so that the Rook can come on
the C file
well there are no games in the database
from this position so let's see the base
continuation from the white
B4 attacking the queen queen to C7 and
white can play Rook to C2 trying to get
the Knight
so Black Knight has to move and after
the queen exchange when White Castle on
the king side I proposed this nice move
Bishop to G4 and I think after this even
though we have equal material black is
completely winning
for example S3
Bishop takes F3 Knight takes F3
and Rook to C8 now you see the important
point of our Bishop
white would love to challenge the C file
but in fact he cannot
okay Knight to H2 trying for the Knight
G4 well we can simply stop it
and if white block of a bishop with F4
ready to play Rook to C1 we have a very
nice move here Knight to defy
and after this just look at the pathetic
placement of all white pieces
that is already ongoing pressure on F4
Rook to C3 is coming in the mix
and to your surprise if you put this
position in any chest engine it says
it's completely winning for the black
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile tricky line
against the London system
I am sure after watching this video you
are as confident as me to burst the
London nuts
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will see you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care